lundi l'affiche officielle de sa
campagne sortira dans toute la France
Jacques Merlino
elle fait 8 m de long sur 3 m de large
elle occupe à elle seul deux panneaux et
innovation le candidat n'apparaît pas
seul mais entouré de 10 hommes et femmes
un choix voulu par Jacques Sila le
concepteur de cette affiche François
miteran pour son premier message
publicitaire à ses électeurs a voulu
leur dire que si l'on voulait changer de
politique il valait changer de président
et que changer de politique c'est
aussi avoir une politique de
concertation et savoir s'entourer des
conseils de ceux qui savent c'estàd de
ceux qui chacun dans leur discipline ont
prouvé quelque chose et ont réussi